so I think it's worth talking a little
bit because like I'm usually talking to
you about safety about the decision that
opening I made to not release the fully
trained model the big one so because
this has not been released we know that
it works like a transformer left to its
own devices without being fine-tuned
it's just a massive amount of data and
off you go is that right yeah like
there's enough information given in the
paper to reproduce it and you just need
the giant giant data set which is a real
hassle to make especially because you
really need high quality data does it
say anywhere in the paper about how long
it took to train yes and how and how
many different how many TP use you need
and stuff like that
what's the TPU that's a tensor
processing unit okay so like a GPU but
fancy you need a lot of money if you
tried to train this with just like
amazon's cloud computing offering you
would be you'd end up with a bill that i
I expect would be in the hundreds of
thousands of pounds like it's a lot of
compute but with all of these things
it's a lot of compute to train them it's
not that much computer run this isn't a
new architecture this isn't like a vast
breakthrough from that perspective it's
just like the same thing but much bigger
and and nobody else is keeping their
research and like not releasing their
models to the public so you know you
think it's dangerous to say that you
think that your work might be dangerous
and you're not releasing it it's kind of
like you think it's much more dangerous
than other people's work and therefore
like it's so powerful that it's
dangerous it's kind of like you're
saying that your stuff is so good that
it's you know it's too powerful for you
you know I can't release it or whatever
I think people reacted in a sense to
that there's just smack a little bit of
publicity stunt I mean assuming it's not
a publicity stunt assume rest is not
that which I don't believe it is what
are they worried about so that the worry
like people make a big people make a big
deal of the
Evette generating fake news like fake
news articles that will convince people
that there are actually unicorns or
whatever I don't think that that's the
risk I also don't think that that's
really what opening I thinks the risk is
if you want to generate a fake thing
it's still not expensive to do that you
can just sit down and write something
right you don't need a language model to
write your fake news and in fact you
don't have that much control over it so
you wouldn't if you were trying to
actually manipulate something you would
want to be tweaking it anyway I don't
think that's the risk the the thing that
the thing that most concerns me about
things like gbg 2 is like the content is
not particularly good but it is
convincingly human and so it creates a
lot of potential for making fake users
and so there is this constant arms race
between bots operators and the big
platforms right there's teams working at
Google at YouTube at Facebook everywhere
working on identifying accounts that
aren't real and there's various ways you
can do that one of the things you can do
is you can analyze the text that they
write because the language models that
are out there aren't very good and so if
some if if an account is like repeating
itself a lot or you have a whole bunch
of accounts that are all saying like
exactly the same thing then you know
that this is like a spam maybe
manipulation attempt and so on but with
GPT too you can have things that produce
you give the same prompt and then you
post all of the outputs and all of those
outputs are different from each other
and they all look like they were written
by a human and it's not a human can look
at them probably and figure out hang on
a second this doesn't quite seem right
but only if you're really really paying
attention which human attention on the
large scale is super expensive right so
much more expensive than the compute
needed to generate the samples so you're
outmatched
if you if you spend more they can spend
it you can you can spend 10 times more
and you yourself financially and
they can spend 10 times more and it's
fine
so you're gonna lose that battle
the other thing is so it becomes very
difficult to identify fake users the
other thing is one way that you can
identify fake users is by analyzing the
graph like the social graph or the
interaction graph and you can see that
[Music]
because humans usually when they see
spam posts that are full of links to
dubious websites and whatever they
download them they don't reply to them
and you can create you can fake the
voting metrics by having these accounts
vote for each other's stuff but then you
can analyze the graph of that and say oh
all of these plate people they all only
vote for each other and the people who
we know are humans like never vote for
them so we assume those are all bots and
we can ignore them but the samples that
gbt to produces the big model are
convincing enough to get actual humans
to engage with them right it's not like
oh my god that's so persuasive I've read
this article and now I believe this
thing about unicorns it's just like I
believe that a real human wrote this
thing and now I want to argue with them
that there aren't unicorns or whatever
right and now you have real humans
engaging in actual meaningful
conversation with BOTS and now you've
got a real problem because how are you
going to spot who the bots are when you
can't do it automatically just by
analyzing the text you can't even do it
by aggregating the human responses to
them because the humans keep thinking
that they're actual humans so now you
have the ability to produce large
amounts of fake users that the platforms
can't spot and therefore they can't stop
those users votes from counting on
things up voting things and down voting
things and liking them and subscriptions
and everything else and maybe plating
the metrics that way one thing people
would do is spot the their profile
pictures if you're trying to generate a
large number of BOTS where are you going
to get your pictures from and so you can
do like reverse image search and get the
find of it and they're all using the
same picture or they're all using
pictures from the same database of
facial photos or whatever now we have
these really good generative adversarial
networks that can generate good-looking
cases so that's now really difficult as
well and like you can't automatically
detect those almost by definition
because the way the gams work the
discriminator is like a state-of-the-art
fake face image detector and it's being
fooled like that's the whole point and
if you released if somebody came up with
a really reliable way of spotting those
fake images then you can just use that
as the discriminator and keep training
right so not releasing their full
strength model to me feels very sensible
in the sense that people will figure it
out right they published the the science
someone will find it it is worth their
while to do it to spend the money to
reproduce these results but by not
releasing it they've bought the
platform's several months to like
prepare for this to understand what's
going on and they are of course working
with them and sharing their full
strength model with selected partners
people they trust to say here's what it
can do take a moment you know govern
yourself accordingly like get ready
because this stuff is going to come but
they're giving everybody a heads up to
mitigate the potential like negative
impacts that this work might have and
the other thing is it sets a really good
precedent I think because maybe GPG -
isn't that dangerous but the stuff that
we're making is just getting more and
more powerful and at some point somebody
is going to develop something that is
really dangerous and by then you want
there to be accepted practices and
social norms and industry standards
about thinking about the impact of your
work before you release it and so it's
good to start with something that like
there's some argument that there could
be some danger from it just so that
everybody is like aware that this is a
thing that you can do and that people
won't think you're weird or you're
bragging or it's a publicity stunt or
whatever to make it like socially okay
to say we found this cool result and
we're not going to put it out there
because we're not sure about the safety
of it and I think that that's something
that's really really necessary so I
think that open AI is very smart to
start that off now
for we really really need it I make a
principled decision now I want the seven
so in principle I should be going this
way right and would think I'd want to
steer towards the seven but on the other
hand at this point it's your choice you
give it some random noise and it
generates an image from that noise and
the idea is its supposed